[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 78 sport vous en avez l'habitude
c'est tous les lundis dans quelques
instants Tony rche va me rejoindre mais
d'abord direction le vélodrome de 50 ans
nieline pour tout comprendre de
l'avancée du
chantier bienvenue dans ce nouveau set h
sport une édition spéciale consacrée au
Vélodrome de 50 ans en yelin le futur
Clairefontaine du cyclisme français à 8
mois de l'ouvert officielle nous allons
vous offrir une visite inédite au cœur
du chantier en compagnie d'arnumaglia
directeur d'exploitation de vélopolice
et François Patrier en charge de la
maîtrise d'ouvrage bonjour à vous
François bonjour alors la première
question qui me brûle les lèvres est-ce
que le chantier que qui est derrière
nous est dans les temps ouioui on est
parfaitement dans les temps il y a il y
a pas de souci particulier à se faire
vous le voyez là aujourd'hui on est en
train de poser le bardage qui sera la
peau finale qu'on verra du du Vélodrome
donc tout se passe bien on est dans les
temps et on espère que ça va aller comme
ça jusqu'au bout en terme
d'investissement il doit y avoir
beaucoup d'effectifs sur le chantier au
jour le jour combien de personnes à peu
près travaille ici que ça soit
directement sur le chantier ou dans les
bureaux sur le mois d'avril d'avril 2013
on est sur des effectifs autour de 140
personnes à peu près euh voilà donc ça
donne une idée un peu de du nombre de
personnes qui peut y avoir sur un projet
comme celui-là uniquement sur le
chantier parce qu'évidemment il y a
énormément d'autres personnes qui
travaillent sur les côtés dans
différents
endroit de Paris et d'autres il y a
énormément de d'acteurs sur ce projet et
voilà et alors vous parliez de
d'objectif vous êtes dans les temps les
objectifs effectifs en terme de travaux
la fin des travaux on pourrait
l'envisager quand on espère le notre
objectif principal c'est de finir
l'ensemble des travaux à la fin du mois
de septembre le le le le vélodrome doit
être mis à disposition en décembre 2013
mais il doit être vraiment livré ce
qu'on appelle clé en main donc on va
faire beaucoup d'essais
entre les mois d'octobre et novembre
2013 on a vraiment un objectif absolu
sur la fin du mois de septembre pour la
fin de tous les travaux sur le vélo et
alors là vous vous parliez du bardage
c'est une étape compliquée une étape
décisive peut-être dans dans symbolique
c'est très symbolique forcément parce
que donc Jean Chaban qui est
l'architecte du du
projet tient énormément à la façade du
bâtiment Vélodrome et voilà donc c'est
c'est c'est avant tout une étape
symbolique la complexité est certaine
mais ça reste quelque chose de de de
faisable mais c'est surtout une image
très très importante forcément tout le
monde a en tête les les perspectives du
Vélodrome donc c'est vraiment très très
important avant de rentrer plus
concrètement à l'intérieur du chantier
est-ce que il y a des des choses et des
étapes innovantes dans dans ce chantier
du du
Vélodrome c'est d'abord avant tout le
bâtiment Vélodrome il a une certaine
complexité dû à sa forme il faut
vraiment comprendre que dans le
vélodrome il y a pas eu presque pas eu
de de mur droit tout est courbe donc ça
ça a été une très grande complexité on a
fait appel à un géomètre à pleintemps
sur le chantier pour
implanter tous les différents ouvrages
ça ça étit une complexité très très
importante maintenant il y a pas
forcément de de de choses très très
innovante en revanche qui est assez
intéressant sur ce projet c'est la piste
en bois forcément on est en en train de
construire une boîte à chaussures la
piste en bois ça va être la chaussure
qu'on va poser à la fin et ça pour le
coup c'est un ouvrage très particulier
l'architecte de cette piste en bois
c'est Ralph Schurman il va également
poser la piste et ça on attend tout ça
avec impatience parce que c'est vraiment
le le point final des de de ces travaux
avant la la pose de lapis justement je
crois qu' en ce moment le la dalle de
l'espace principal est écoulée je vous
propose d'y aller on se retrouve là-bas
dans quelques instants très
[Musique]
bien
nous sommes à présent à l'intérieur du
Vélodrome sur les futurs gradins la
partie inférieure des gradins toujours
en compagnie de François Patrier en
charge de la maîtrise d'ouvrage alors
François là je vois derrière nous que la
D est en train d'être coulé hein donc
c'est une étape décisive j'imagine dans
dans la dans la porsuite du chantier
exactement donc là ce que vous voyez
c'est la la dalle de l'air centrale donc
c'est à peu près 2700 m² de de béton qui
vont être coulés au milieu
c'est le le le lieu où vont avoir lieu
une grande partie des activités du
Vélodrome en dehors du cyclusme sur
piste vous voyez l'anneau qui se trouve
autour qui est l'anneau sur lequel va
reposer la piste en bois mais donc l'air
centrale est également une étape
importante pour le chantier
puisque ça va servir de de base pour le
constructeur de la piste puisqu'il va
faire tous ces tous ces petits montages
de Lego en fait c'est c'est comme des
Lego ou des des Caplat ils vont il va
les faire dans l'air central et ensuite
il va monter sa piste sur l'anneau et
alors elle est évidemment possible cette
cette piste et le coulage de la dalle
parce que la charpente au-udessus je
vois qu'elle est qu'elle est terminée he
toute la charpente du toit est terminée
al Act exactement donc là au-dessus de
notre tête on est à peu près 1000 tonne
d'acier ce qui est quand même assez
important c'est quoi c'est pas très très
courant même en
île-de-fance et cette charpente est
terminé depuis maintenant quelques
semaines la couverture également est en
passe d'être d'être
terminée voilà on commence un peu à
avoir la forme finale du Vélodrome et à
partir de quand justement vous parliez
de la piste bah voilà le le le montage
de Lego va commencer alors il est prévu
que le constructeur de la piste arrive à
partir de début août donc les toutes
premières lattes seront posées à partir
du 12 août très précisément en tout cas
c'est comme ça qu'on l' vu dans le
calendrier et donc la fin de la piste
c'est fin septembre je vois derrière
vous notamment et derrière moi aussi des
aérations il y a encore des trous d'air
un petit peu dans dans ce vélodrome
c'est normal ou c'est c'est parfaitement
normal il faut il faut prendre le temps
quand même de finir le chantier et donc
on a des objectif qu'il n'y ait plus
d'entrée d'eau donc ce qu'on appelle le
hors d'eau fin avril donc à la fin de ce
mois-ci et hors d'air donc plus d'air
qui rentre à l'intérieur à partir de la
fin du mois de mai d'accord très bien
merci beaucoup François pour cette
visite guidée je vous en
prie nous continuons notre visite guidée
du vélodrome de 50 ans en nel en
compagnie cette fois-ci d'arnaagila
directeur d'exploitation de vélopolice
bonjour à vous bonjour alors nous
faisons partie des privilégiés j'ai
envie de dire puisque nous sommes
sûrement les premier assis sur cette
tribune du futur Vélodrome comment va
s'articuler cet espace immense au final
tout à fait en fait cet espace
s'articule sur trois niveaux l'air
centrale qui est ici en bas où se
dérouleront la plupart des
manifestations et des activités sportive
le niveau qu'on appelle R+ 2 donc le
premier niveau de gradin où on pourra
héberger à peu près 4000 spectateurs
suivant les événements et puis un niveau
supérieur au 3è étage où là nous
pourrons accueillir un petit millier de
spectateurs également avec accès à un
salon de réception qui donne vue
panoramique sur la piste juste derrière
et alors vous parliez de la piste
justement cette piste sera unique au
monde puisque elle aura des dimensions
assez incroyables en fait c'est ça oui
on l'appelle un peu la la piste au
record enfin en tout cas on espère 250 m
de long 8 m de large qui permet au
coureurs de prendre beaucoup plus d'élan
depuis le haut des virages et donc
d'essayer d'optimiser les milè de
secondes qui qui sont nécessaires à
aller chercher les records le vélodrome
n'aura pas aussi que vocation à
accueillir des compétitions cyclistes il
y aura d'autres activités et des
configurations différentes en fonction
c'est ça tout à fait l'air centrale fait
à peu près 3000 m² donc donc dans cette
configuration nous pouvons accueillir à
la fois des concerts d'autres types
d'événements sportifs type handball
basketball volleyball ou tout a autre
type de manifestation et puis ils se
dérouleront également sur C terre
centrale des activités quotidiennes qui
nous permettront de de faire de ce
vélodrome un lieu de vie pour tous les
tous les tous les gens de 50 ans d' VI
oui parce qu'il faut le rappeler le
vélodrome ce ne sera pas que des
compétitions internationale de vélo au
quotidien vous avez comme objectif voilà
d'en faire un lieu de vie tout à fait on
est sur un ratio à peu près de 25 % de
taux d'occupation de l'élite donc de la
Fédération française de cyclisme et 75 %
ouverte au grand public et aux
événements sportifs et au final donc ce
taux d'occupation de 25 % ça sera
uniquement rez-de-chaussée
principalement rez-de-chaussée pour les
pour l'élite ce sera principalement
rez-de-chaussée et piste he puis que
c'est ce qu'on intègre alors piste du
vélodrome et piste de BMX voilà et donc
on aura donc cet espace VIP qui sera sur
notre gauche là-bas le salon olympique
pour l'instant voilà VIP convention en
fait en fonction de la configuration
tion événementielle ce salon sera VIP ou
grand public selon les organisations qui
se qui se dérouleront sur l'air centrale
ou dans l'enceinte du Vélodrome j'en
parlais tout à l'heure avec François
c'est une course cont laamonde pour le
chantier en lui-même mais c'est aussi
sûrement le même la même chose pour vous
j'imagine en tant que directeur
d'exploitation tout à fait il reste à
peu près 6 mois on va dire avant
l'ouverture du Vélodrome il reste
beaucoup beaucoup de chantiers en uvre
toute la programmation 2014 à pouvoir
caler les partenaires répondre aussi à
l'ensemble des sollicitations naturelles
qui viennent à nous ce qui est plutôt
positif mais effectivement il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire ou
oui parce qu'on est en avril 2013 mais
vous pensez déjà 2014 on parle déjà des
championnats de France notamment de de
sur PIST qui qui se dérouleront début
2014 c'est déjà dans les tiroirs comme
on dit c'est dans les tiroirs c'est
l'ensemble de la programmation est dans
les tiroirs jusqu'à décembre 2014 et
alors vous avez hâte que ça soit fini
qu'on voit cette piste arriver et naître
ici à 550 an eneline oui la piste
l'ensemble des éléments qui qui font que
on va retrouver une enceinte propre
prête prête à être exploité et qui vont
nous donner la vision réelle de ce que
va être de ce que va être ce vélodrome
le bardage extérieur l'aménagement des
espaces également donc oui oui on est on
a hâte et en même temps on sait ce qui
nous reste à faire donc chaque jour et
chaque chaque heure est compté le chemin
est encore long au final peut-être on
voit la la dalle qui se coule devant nos
yeux mais il reste encore beaucoup de
choses que auquel on ne pense pas tout
de suite quand on rentre vraiment dans
le détail de tout ce qui reste à faire
il reste vraiment énorme éormément de de
choses je suis pas inquiet sur sur les
délais à délivrer l'ensemble de ces
éléments mais effectivement il y a
jusqu'au moindre détail tout est pensé
tout est revu tout est reconsidéré pour
être sûr qu'on sera vraiment dans les
conditions optimum d'ouverture à la fin
décembre merci beaucoup Arnaud de de
cette visite guidée en compagnie aussi
de de François Patrier et puis nous
espérons revenir quand la piste bah sera
posée tout simplement bienvenue merci
beaucoup
merci voilà Anthony vous avez quitté le
vélodrome vous avez de la chance he ou
franchement ça fait rêé de voir ce début
de piste se se créer bon c'est du Goudon
pour l'instant mais voir ce début de de
piste et puis j'ai juste envie de poser
une question à Jean-Manuel mort vous
êtes vous c'est le tennis de table à
encour c'est pas le cycliste mais ça
vous fait rêver vous voyez ce vélo de ah
oui j'y passe tous les jours devant
alors
bonjour passe tous les jours devant et
oui bah on a espoir peut-être un jour de
d'organiser peut-être une manifestation
dedans alors en attendant la grande
manifestation qui sera peut-être au
Vélodrome il y en a une autre je laisse
la main à an qui vous concerne plus
directement dans 15 jours le mondial de
tennis de table va avoir lieu donc au
palé Omnisport de Paris Bery et avant
cela il y a une sorte de de tour un
petit peu dans des villes villes étapes
en France et notamment à hencour donc le
club est est ville étape et club étape
de de ce ping mondial ping tour tout
simplement donc ce ce weekend alors
expliquez-moi un peu déjà comment vous
avez été sélectionné pour pour faire un
peu la promotion de ce sport voilà alors
déjà oui effectivement il y a les
championnats du monde qui se déroulent à
Bercy du 13 au 20 mai c'est assez
exceptionnel c'est les seuls
championnats du monde qui sont organisés
euh en France en 2013 et la Fédération
Française de Tennis de Table a souhaité
à cette occasion mettre en avant le le
tennis de table et promouvoir cette
pratique auprès de un plus large public
que les licenciés et alors du coup là
sur cette journée en cours au Palais des
Sports qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
découvrir ou faire alors vous allez
pouvoir découvrir le le tennis table
dans toutes ses formes et pas forcément
celle qu'on imagine sous la forme de
compétition de match mais également de
la découverte pour pour les les plus
petits euh de la découverte d'un
nouvelle pratique qui commence à à faire
son chemin c'est le fitping c'est-à-dire
le tennis de table en musique en danse
alors en danse autour de la table
comment ça passe exactement alors venez
voir vous verrez comment ça s'organise
ça sport rythmé alors oui ça sera rythmé
alors il y aura du step il y aura
effectivement des mouvements et on va
bien sûr pas faire des grosses
chorégraphies mais c'est l'objectif
c'est de mêler de
pratique la danse et le et le tennis de
table et alors au Baby ping comment on
fait pour adapter justement l'espace
puisquon sait qu'il y a voilà il y a la
hauteur de la table alors bien sûr nous
allons avoir des toutes petites tables à
la hauteur des des plus jeunes 4 5 ans
pour qu'ils aient la 4 an 4 ans oui les
meilleurs ont tous commencé à cet âge là
oui et il s'agit juste d'un d'une
question de coordination de de vision
dans
l'espace certains sont sont plus matur
que d'autres à 4 ans et alors sur votre
programmation pardon j'ai vu le 6
stepping il y a marqué surprise alors ça
c'est une surprise Antony on peut pas le
dire mais estmemanuel vous êtes obligé
de nous dire ce de quoi il s'agit ex C
ping c'est une marque locale donc dans
le cadre de de cette étape de promotion
nous avons nous également défini un
univers de découverte du tennis de table
selon nos propres notre propre vision
alors il y aura des surprises il y aura
du virtuel il y aura du technique il y
aura du robot il y aura des des choses
comme ça ça c'est quelque chose 100 % il
en cours 100% il en cours oui d'accord
nous l'avions déjà organisé pardon
allez-yy nous l'avions déjà organisé
l'an dernier uniquement et en cours sous
cette forme là et les C cantinois qui
vont venir donc au Palais des Sports ce
weekend vont pouvoir se frotter un petit
peu à la crème du du tennis de table
ivelinois ou même national international
alors il est prévu effectivement de
pouvoir échanger des balles avec les
joueurs les meilleurs et puis d'autres
d'un niveau régional départemental il
est prévu un espace compétition où
chacun va pouvoir se mesurer entre eux
et les meilleurs pourront être
sélectionné pour les finales ces étapes
se déroulant dans 90 villes en France
chacun des des meilleurs se rencontrera
à Bery et alors vous en parliez un petit
peu tout à l'heure c'est le seul gros
événement mondial en terme de sport en
2013 en France c'est important c'est un
trempelin même d'avoir un mondial comme
ça dans dans son pays alors la maison
comme dit ça peut être une vraie
dynamique en terme d'image en terme de
de promotion à partir du moment où
effectivement il y a des résultat on va
dire français tout
simplement ce qui ne sera pas facile
cette année oui c'est c'est à cause de
ça que ça prend pas vraiment le le
tennis de table ou le ping comme on
dit c'est la problématique de de
beaucoup de sports c'est la la diffusion
et justement les chances françaises vous
pensez qu'il peut y en avoir on pense à
Adrien mat NOTAM ement deux jeunes
Adrien matenet et Simon gozi qui
viennent d'être titré champion de France
ce
weekend ça va être tout de même très
difficile face au aux Asiatiques il y a
une armada de chinois de japonais de
Coréens qui sont sur le papier plus fort
maintenant on compte sur eux pour se
transcender à domicile cette on va dire
cette défaillance un petit peu des
joueurs français c'est dû à la grosse
concurrence qui a en Pro A et en Pro B
il y a beaucoup de joueus et joueurs
étrangèr j'en ai déjà parlé avec Fran
Sony l'entraîneur de probé qui dit qui
me disait voilà il y a beaucoup de J
étrangères les championnats sont déjà
très relevés alors pour n joueurs à nous
c'est compliqué c'est pas forcément une
défaillance hein la plupart des autres
pays européens sont dans la même
situation hormis l'Allemagne qui fait
exception mais même la Suède qui a eu
une grosse grosse génération sont
maintenant plus en difficulté et quant à
l'apport des étrangers dans dans le
championnat français il y a les deux
côtés qui qui rentrent en balance il y a
le côté de de pratiquer avec les
meilleurs et les les meilleurs qui fait
progresser également les les Français et
les Françaises et puis c'est vrai on
peut dire que ils prennent la place des
des Français et des françaises mais je
suis pas persuadé tenise de table en
France a quand même connu une heure des
heures de gloire grâce à des champions
tels que Secrétin ou gen bon ça remonte
effectivement à quelques années voilà ça
fait 20 ans pourit 21s voilà donc c'est
vrai que ça ça remonte un petit peu mais
alors à ces mondiaux et encour va être
présent un petit peu indirectement mais
l' encours sera présent voilà alors une
de nos joueuses de directement allonsy
Maria christophora qui est effectivement
qualifié pour ces championnats du monde
donc on compte sur elle pour représenter
voilà membre l'équipe de prob et puis on
a également notre entraîneur qui va le
la coacher pendant cette compétition
elle va découvrir les championnat du
monde je crois il me semble c'est ça ça
sera une belle expérience puisque Fran
Sony aussi c'est aussi une belle
aventure pouri aussi ça sera une
découverte mais là du coup elle va pas
concourir sous les couleurs de la France
non voous les couleurs par qu'elle elle
est grecque et alors avant le Mondial il
y avait les championnats
ce weekend on va rester en terme
national et là il y a eu des bonnes
performances aussi du côté des lancours
puisque penelops notamment c'est
illustré nous avions deux joueuses qui
étaient qualifié au championnat de
France c'est-à-dire Penelope sol et
Annesophie
Jean pénéope était par ailleurs qualifié
au championnat universitaire où elle a
été titrée donc médaille d'or en double
et médaille d'argent en simple aux
universitaires et au championnat de
France senior les deux de joueuses ont
fait un beau
parcours puisque elles ont dû abdiquer
uniquement en 16e de finale sur beaucoup
plus fort qu'elle très bien donc ce ser
ça montre un peu leur belle saison aussi
en probé oui nous sommes très satisfaits
de cette saison oui super merci beaucoup
Jean Emmanuel d'être venu ce soir et
donc du coup rendez-vous dimanche au
Palais des Sports entre 9h et 18h voilà
venez très nombreux dimanche donc au
Palais des Sports 9h 18h je juste une
petite question parce que vous parlez du
jeu en double est-ce que est-ce qu'il y
a des couples qui jouent au ping-pong en
double des couples mari et femme oui euh
je ne sais pas j'en vois point comme ça
de tête ça ça joue mais ben parce
queantthony vous en avez rencontré vous
mais c'est au badmintonou cé au
badminton on reste dans le monde de la
raquette mais c'était au badminton ce
weekend voisin Bretonneux le club de
voisin Bretonneux organisé son
traditionnel tournoi régional au
programme simple double et double mixte
nous nous sommes d'ailleurs intéressés à
cette compétition toujours un peu imp
part où la cohabitation sur le terrain
entre hommes et femmes et parfois
difficile surtout quand on est en couple
image de Patrick Jacques de dixmud
en théorie le double est toujours
l'épreuve la plus conviviale d'un
tournoi et surtout le double mixte mais
ça c'est seulement en théorie Magalie et
Laurent en couple dans la vie ont vite
séparer les raquettes sur le terrain
ouais mais parce que des fois tu as des
histoires de couple qui ressortte tout
ça sur le terrain c'est pas bon mieux
vaut ne pas avoir d'histoire de couple
sur le terrain quoi voilà c'est ça bah
tu sais pas ce qui s'est passer la
veille voilà qui sa qui a pas fait la
vaisselle ou des choses comme ça quoi de
l'autre côté du filet Jean-Christophe et
Mary en couple également jouent ensemble
depuis 2 ans et demi leur secret ce qui
se passe sur le terrain reste au bord du
filet je pense qu'il y a plein de choses
on se connaît bien mais après on se dit
aussi plus facilement les reproches donc
c'est voilà c'est ça le souci c'est
qu'il faut jongler à ce niveau-là voilà
faut dire les choses avec
diplomatie la réussite du double mix
passe donc par la diplomatie et surtout
une excellente stratégie la femme joue
le plus souvent il est à coup d'amorti
l'homme couvre le fond du terrain malgré
leur entente avec une victoire et une
défaite maris et Jean-Christophe ne
verront pas le tableau final de leur
côté Magalie et Laurent attendent de
s'échanger quelques match en phase
finale on connait le jeu de l're on
connait les faiblesses les points forts
c'est pas pareil ça vous fait peur rien
pas du tout je sais que j'ai gagné la
finale dans ces CASL si je la rend
compte et place maintenant au principaux
résultats sport du
weekend
place tout d'abord au football en
division d'honneur versaill a concédé le
match nul 0 à0 face à Mo en match en
retard de la 16e journée en promotion
d'honneur match en retard également de
la 12e journée cette fois- si gui en
cour est inclinée sur la pelouse de
saintmort 3-1 les joueurs d'Étienne
Ridet subissent là leors 5e défaite
consécutive et il dégingol littéralement
au classement de cette poule c'est de
promotion d'unur d'ailleurs je vous
propose de de regarder ce classement
alors qu'il trenait en tête he du
championnat la trêve cet hiver leesg
désormais 8e avec 44 points à 14
longueurs du leader Lina monleri il est
temps que la saison se termine pour
l'aiguille en courtois dans la poule B
trappe recevait la lanterne rouge
l'espérance Paris 19e ce weekend les
traapistes en bleu sur votre écran voilà
ils apparaissent ont fait preuve de
réalisme au stade Gilbert chansac sur la
première frappe ils ouvrent le score
après un dédoublement côté gauche voilà
la frappe petit filet magnifique croisé
Gabriel hernodot déclenche d'ailleurs
cette frappe à 25 m hors de portée du
gardien les joueurs d'Hervé duc mettent
alors le pied sur le ballon mais ils se
font surprendre à la suite d'un coup
franc il la défense 5antinoise cafouille
complètement voilà on voit le toute la
défense qui est complètement à l'arrêt
un partout après 25 minutes de jeu avant
la mi-temps Trapp ajoutera un second but
par l'intermédiaire de Dominique menoir
un dernier but en seconde période c le
match score final 3-1 avec ce succès les
traapistes confortent leur 3e place au
classement allez Antony on va rester
dans le monde du football mais là on va
aller à l'intérieur oui au foutsal
Catherine ce weekend avait lieu les
finales de la coupe des ivelines les
féminines d'élancour malgré une belle
résistance n'ont rien pu faire face au
PSG s'incline 10 buts à 3 mais les élan
courtois se sont rattrapés grâce à leur
U17 les moins de 17 ans qui se sont
imposés 7 à 6 sur le fil face au moi il
réalise là le doublé en deux saisons
consécutif on va changer de sport on va
parler rugby et puis je rappelle que la
finale de la Coupe d'Europe ça sera
entre deux équipes françaises Clermont
et Toulon alors ça c'est pour avoir le
petit cocoico de la soirée mais sur
notre secteur c'était le 32e de finale
du championnat de France fédéral oui
plaisir est passé tout proche de
l'exploit à rouan en match retour les
joueurs de Philippe Bard ne s'inclinent
que de CIN petits points 23 à 18 malgré
deux essais inscrits ils sortent quand
même la tête haute de ces play-offs en
finale régionale de Promotion d'Honneur
Rambouillet a réalisé un doublé
historique ce weekend l'équipe première
a conquis le titre face à Sergi Pontois
sur le score de 14 à 10 les vers ont
fait la différence dans les toutes
dernières minutes du match et un petit
peu plus tôt dans la journée et bien la
réserve s'était imposée sur le fil 20 à
18 face au chînet alle on continue avec
du basket il y a une bonne et puis il y
a une mauvaise nouvelle ouais la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ça continue de
rigoler hein pour les féminines de
l'Entente le chîn et Versailles 2è
journée de play-off de National 2 les
filles de vinobardic se sont imposé à
l'arrachée à Sainte Savine 67 à 62 après
prolongation les coéquipière de Chantal
Descoins ont désormais un pied en
National une mais l'information du
weekend elle vient de trappe et cette
26e et dernière journée 1 de National 2
c'est ce queon pressentait depuis
quelques semaines d'ailleurs malgré sa
victoire chez le dernier mob 67 à 53
trappe n'a pas réussi à se maintenir en
National 2 car dans le même temps en
fait Horm s'est imposé 107 à 101 face à
Angers et donc du coup au classement et
ben évidemment les trapistes sont
toujours dans la zone rouge après après
cette saison régulière 12e et relégable
devant leement et mobug un tout petit
point malheureusement du maintien à
Horme et dorme c'est une une page qui se
tourne pour l'étoile des chemineaux de
trappe ouais c'est clair al c'est
vraiment dommage hein pourou après avoir
frollé en plus la montée en Nationale 1
la saison dernière c'est ah ou ça
faisait quand même quelques années
qu'ils était en Nationale 2 c'est
vraiment dommage pour eux allez on va
par parler du baseball maintenant
Montini qui se maintient 4e journée de
Division 2 et les coupgard de Montini se
déplaçai chez le leader Pessac il
s'incline sèchement dans le premier
match un 19 à 0 mais les joueurs
d'arnaofo se sont bien repris
l'après-midi en s'imposant 6 points à qu
il reste 2e de cette division 2 derrière
Charre et puis des résultats en football
américain c'est dur hein pour les
juniors après une belle saison régulière
oui quart de finale de play-off de
championnat de France junior conférence
nord et les Templiers bah se sont
inclinés et même ils se sont fait étrier
he samedi soir 31-0 par les corsaires
d'EV malgré cette lourde défaite C cette
saison reste positive après le néant
tout simplement dans la saison 2011-2012
et quelques petites infos en plus oui
trois petites infos en football à morpa
on salue la belle saison des moins 17
ans de Laas morpa invaincu après 15
journées ils ont été sacrés champions
d'excellence ce weekend et évolueront la
saison prochaine en division d'honneur
régionale toujours en football l'entente
sportif de guancour organise c'est des
détections he cette semaine pour ses
Huin c'estes moins de 15 ans et c'estes
moins de 17 ans qui évolu déjà en DHR ce
jeudi 2 mai à 17h30 au gymnase des
droits de l'homme et puis une dernière
enquête qui va faire plaisir à tous les
îles Vinois puisque le département est
décidément très sportif et oui on en
parle tout le temps évidemment nous
sommes très sportifs une étude TNS sofr
et du Comité Régional de Tourisme Paris
Île-de-France publié jeudi a démontré
que les evines seraient le département
le plus sportif de la région avec 78 %
d'adeptes contre 50 % dans la capitale
oui voilà vous êtes sportif vous Antony
ah oui on essaye on essaye voilà ok
merci en tout cas c'est fini pour cette
ce 78 sport rendez-vous donc lundi
prochain oui d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à
le commenter ce 78 sport sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag le 78 sport tout
attaché et nous donner tous les
résultats de vos clubs à lundi prochain
bonne
[Musique]
soirée